hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is your first look at the brand new
samsung galaxy s 20 and galaxy s20 plus
now there's a whole new lineup of
samsung phones out right now they're
going all out for 2020 clearly so we
have the galaxy s20 the galaxy s20 plus
and a new galaxy s20 ultra i've dropped
an entire separate video on that s20
ultra it's the new pro version in their
lineup but that phone starts
starts at 13.99 and we don't all have a
g and a half to spend on a new phone no
matter how nice it is so these are the
true successors to the galaxy s10 and
s10 plus the s20 and s20 plus and to me
this is actually one of the biggest
jumps up i've seen samsung take with
their phones literally everything you
can think of is upgraded and they've
taken the biggest jumps in the most
important areas of the phone so the
screen
the battery and the cameras so let's
start with the screen these are now 6.2
inch and 6.7 inch displays respectively
and they are 120 hertz quad hd
oled displays so super high resolution
hdr plus and super responsive high
refresh rate screens this is the train
i've been telling you guys flagships are
all going to get on in 2020 and to match
that super high refresh rate samsung has
also doubled the touch sensitivity to a
240hz sample rate meaning it responds to
touch input twice as fast and the whole
new speed difference is instantly
noticeable now obviously it's still
tough for me to show you guys in this a
30fps youtube video
but yeah literally everything from
swiping around the ui to opening and
closing apps and scrolling and
eventually of course gaming everything
will look and feel smoother and i think
samsung has also tweaked some of these
animations in one ui to be a bit shorter
and snappier too so you can easily tell
it feels
way smoother than 60 hertz and i can
actually tell the difference versus 90
as well which i've gotten used to
hey editor marquez here real quick with
a little message a little asterisk so
galaxy s20s at 120 hertz are actually
going to be limited to 1080p
not full resolution 1440p so this is
something i just found out later after
the briefing i didn't even really notice
while using it but
if you get the phone out the box it will
be at 1440p
and at 60hz and when you go into the
settings to change it to move it up to
120hz it'll lock you at 1080p probably
to save battery life and power and
things like that small asterisk on what
we've learned about the phone but
figured i'd let you know
back to the video
so i'm super happy about the screen and
on top of all that there's now uh the
center hole punch you can see which
actually prefer because unlike the
corners there's usually nothing being
blocked in the middle and it's now
actually flatter which is so unlike
samsung because they've always been the
ones to push the curved glass melting
over the sides but hey new decade new
samsung now this display doesn't melt
over the edge nearly as much or kind of
at all it's much more flat and in my
opinion much more usable and they still
have the ultrasonic fingerprint reader
of course underneath the display now
let's talk about battery for a second
they have increased the battery sizes on
all these phones by a healthy amount too
so it's a 4 000 milliamp hour battery on
a smaller s20 and a 4 500 milliamp hour
battery on the s20 plus so they're not
trying to make these phones super razor
thin which is great they're actually
just a tiny bit thicker but it's also
probably because with a huge
bright 120 hertz display
you're gonna want all the battery you
can get so this is something we're gonna
have to test of course when we get the
phone in for the full review but i'm at
least glad to see on the spec sheet much
larger cells plus there's still 25 watt
fast charging with that charger included
in the box and wireless charging too uh
and while we're at it let's hit the
specs boom there you go high-end cpu an
insane 12 gigabytes of ram on all of
them expandable storage ip68 certified i
mean these phones are complete on the
spec sheet not quite as wild as the s20
ultra but still no big shortcomings as
you'd expect from a samsung flagship and
the entire lineup is also all 5g capable
but i don't think this is quite a game
changer as much as some people will try
to make it out to be
you know the s20 and s20 plus they will
not do millimeter wave so only sub 6 5g
and so it'll say 5g in the corner but we
talked about this in a previous video
it's only going to be up to about 20
faster than good 4g on a good day and so
i wouldn't buy this phone just for the
5g so anyway let's hit the last and
probably most important new piece of
these new phones with the galaxy s20 and
that is the cameras they are a huge
focus for samsung in these new phones
this year pun intended and i haven't
seen the unpacked slideshow slides yet
i'm recording this before that but i'd
be willing to bet that
probably half of them at least half
are about cameras so you're looking at a
new triple camera setup for the s20 and
the s20 plus has room for an extra depth
sensor but otherwise they're the same
things here with a new 12 megapixel main
sensor at f 1.8 then there's a 3x 64
megapixel telephoto camera at f2 and a
12 megapixel ultra wide at f 2.2 and
they are all physically larger sensors
than last year which is great for pretty
much everything light sensitivity low
light performance and anything else
basically to do with photography and
there's some serious zoom capabilities
not just optical zoom but with software
giving you a 10x multiplier that's going
to give you a comfortable 30x hybrid
zoom and i know this isn't a video about
the ultra but that phone has a 10x zoom
which means the hybrid zoom with
software will go up to a hundred x which
is ridiculous
but they'll call all of this space zoom
it could have called a galaxy zoom but i
guess that works as well but the nice
cherry on top of all this is they're all
capable of 8k
24 fps video across the whole lineup now
8k video in a smartphone camera
sounds incredible sounds like something
i put in my dream phone but there is a
catch 4k was already big but 8k video is
33 megapixels per frame
which is awesome because you can get the
flexibility of being able to pull 33
megapixel stills from a video
but to get that you have to have a
window of a sensor big enough to shoot
8k video which means you need at least a
33 megapixel sensor but the main camera
on these phones like i mentioned
is that 12 megapixel sensor
it's the 3x telephoto
that's 64 megapixels so when you go into
the settings and turn the video
resolution to 8k like i did that's going
to be coming from that telephoto camera
not the main camera so it's gonna punch
in a bit as you can tell which
definitely drops it a bit on the
convenience side also 8k doesn't support
tracking autofocus or video effects some
things to note as it says here in the
settings so they do technically shoot 8k
yes but it's not from the main sensor
it's punched in there's just a little
bit extra to think about when maxing out
video on these phones so it's not like
the dream world where we can stream 8k
over 5g to youtube without even thinking
about it just not quite there yet either
way though as you can tell
with the entire rest of this phone
not a whole lot to dislike even a lot of
the little stuff they changed i'm liking
too they changed the button situation so
now the buttons have moved back over to
the right hand side and the dedicated
bixby button is gone
uh they're also pretty lightweight
phones as well despite their size and
the bigger batteries i was impressed
with how good they feel in the hand and
how light they are compared to some
other big phones
and samsung's one ui 2.0
has some neat improvements as well now
i'd be lying if i said i loved it um
it's still far from my favorite flavor
of android but there's still things like
building a zoom preview into the camera
app now so when you're zoomed in super
far you still get that preview in the
top left of what the hell you're zooming
into which is super useful and there's
other stuff like spotify now integrated
into bixby routines and hd google duo
video chat built natively into the
dialer and some other stuff like the
subtle new animations and there's also a
new single take mode in the camera
it's like the opposite of pro mode
basically instead of you doing all the
hard work of taking several photos and
videos you just hit the shutter button
once and point it at some action and
it'll decide for you when to take photos
and videos based on you know when eyes
are open and faces are smiling and stuff
that seems kind of cool but this isn't
something i think i'll ever use call me
crazy but i like taking the photos
myself but at the end of the day
if you look back at this whole thing you
get on the spec sheet and everything
they've done with this phone
it's hard to find anything you could
consider
a weakness or a complaint or a downside
or a bad thing about this phone aside
from maybe the price now of course a lot
of this is on paper and based on like
the two hours that i spent with this
phone getting this footage but honestly
i'm excited to review this phone
definitely subscribe to be among the
first to see that when it comes out if
you haven't already
yeah is it too early to call samsung a
front-runner for the most improved award
just based on how many things are better
about this phone i don't know something
to think about either way thanks for
watching and definitely check out the
galaxy s20 ultra video first link with a
like button if you haven't already
watched that check that one out too
catch you guys in the next one
peace